Vernon Smith received a 2002 Nobel
Memorial prize in economic Sciences for
his pioneering work in experimental
economics Joel Biden decided to write
600 checks per month for all kinds of
people
who were sitting at home and not
producing any Goods because of covet
well that's not you you can't stimulus
they call us stimulus there's nothing to
stimulate it's it's it would be like
during the second world war having a
stimulus well you didn't need it you
needed the reverse
and so you know that's going to be
inflationary and
and of course the FED fully accommodated
that whatever of that debt wouldn't be
held by private citizens they they
bought enough from existing private
citizens that they were willing to buy
the new debt right you know the Federal
Reserve is not supposed to buy it
directly but it's the same